they each threat he changed they stret
retirement while all those who smells
every threat you place next family
you're not getting better
[Music]
make me stop much other hand in there
you're going around your budget
[Music]
I'm in I meant your energy is what's
makes me fall rock it
[Music]
Oh
correction is everyone
[Music]
you you don't have any initiative hi get
in there there's a float there's a
floating back yet
[Music]
yes
you kept your not important so the
technique is teaching you a geometry
it's a organization drill but it's the
mindset drill - okay so a motives
mindset is rule entry mindset is this a
mindset of yesterday you grabbed the gun
and right and it was almost dead oops it
will do it to you every time
[Music]
and you're used to this you see oh you
have time to get ready but know it oh
whoa
[Music]
okay
it but you're not really getting night
[Music]
let's go gain it and keep it come on
you don't have the online
[Music]
hey partners me how you see how you went
to protect yourself yes okay so I cease
working on this initiative you don't get
overwhelmed by his aggressiveness that's
what that's the job of wicked hey hey
but if he never works on his
aggressiveness and I don't work on
centeredness in the face of aggression
and I just become a victim like you were
okay so I'm just I've taken the same
Timmy in under staring at him in
complete acceptance
[Music]
soon virtually non-stop yeah
let's go
one Corrections everyone
[Music]
see your braid your baby rocking going
the wrong way
you lost your mind under stress lost
your mind
[Music]
wrong grip lost your mind
come on like that floating movement is
wrong
[Music]
did your internal going get your
internals keep your feet under you hey
get your turn on two more get your
insights goes flower
good this is like that power go take it
take whatever comes two more
feet up to you you almost got it broke
come on Tom don't put our toes like that
again this messes babies you in
[Music]
Hey
try not to expose your elbow
[Music]
everybody's already
they're fine go come on
you got to get these internal skills to
go these techniques
one
but you can have the wrong geometry
[Music]
your knees get down very strong
dumb each side
[Music]
first our city
I have a sphere or orientation not like
this like a lot of your doing them oh
that's heavy
okay come on hey
all they certainly had nothing by
getting the balance offer except yours
now moving your torso
[Music]
we never don't go around there they
force you about
[Music]
you can feel under here
hi
[Music]
down inside down
we don't picture you take the bus
they're coming in my opening which meant
you weren't responding last time who are
dancing there were 40 brats
don't be choreographed you don't do
anything but penetrate the targets with
the required grip go
[Music]
don't go to the fight at all
make your comment inside a little of
life see it's here
should it corrected it back you're going
to still do this same fade opening right
let's go
like you cross the line right
[Music]
all these guess what why don't we keep
this nasal opening we keep working on
that so I can show here right you see
but not for rude ah I'm gonna have to do
it quicker oh I could fade more little
then around
Lucille tempo let's do it quick wide
oh let's do that oh let's try that to go
I'll shed on the hill yo somos control
[Music]
so the less skin you have in the group
town let's slow down elbow tunicate
under your control
[Music]
that's a lot of young
around the energy so once this door
opens that's why we hated it
so I neutralize the risk and I step to
them
now I'm gonna bring the elbow to me then
I go make sure that it comes to me by
going it going to it but that elbow
parts this thing will comes in almost it
elbow comes in and it goes around we're
up
[Music]
okay let's neutralize the grip otherwise
it slows you down